JoJosée Legault Michel David
ChChristian Dufour bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Amos Hussain Pierre Paul St-
PIPIierre Plamondon qui dit
fifinalement que je n'irai pas
dadans ces Marry Victorin on
écécoute reviens.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON
chchef, Parti québécois
- - Il y a des risques de défai,
pupuis il y a des chances
trtrès bonnes de victoire.
OnOn a une excellente candidatue
anancrée localement,
etet la réalité, c'est que
j'j'ai pas d'ancrage et que j'ai
chchoisi ma circonscription déj.
OnOn a un plan. On le suit.
PuPuis moi, je continue le travl
dede terrain que je m'étais engé
àà faire et qui est tellement
imimportant.
- - José, qu'est-ce en pensée?
- - Je pense que la seule choseà
fafaire c'est de ne pas se poinr
dadans un pièce comme ça.
DeDe toute manière les problèmes
dudu Parti québécois sont plus
lalarges que ceux de M. St-Piere
PaPaul St-PIierre Plamondon. N'a
papas besoin d'épiloguer longtes
llà-dessus et quand il avait une
soson point de presse, il avait
didit : j'ai une stratégie pour
MaMarie Victorin. Il avait fait
alallusion à la possibilité qu'l
y y ait un code ou une candidate
dede stature nationale, et c'est
cece qui promet encore on verra.
- - Michel David, en même temps
c'c'est une circonscription
pépéquiste depuis 40 ans?
- - C'est une château fort et vs
sasavez la leçon château fort
pépéquiste, y a aucun comté au
QuQuébec et même parmi ceux
ememboîtés par le PQ qui pourrat
êêtre causé comme sur.
CeCeci étant dit Monsieur Paul -
PIPIierre Plamondon serait bien
fofou de ce placer là-dedans pae
quque la défaite est assurée.
LeLe message que ça envoie et qe
lele candidat qui va se présent,
sisi le SAMU se fait pas il y...
ilil faut un Qaïda qui a un
memeilleur ancrage. Il reste que
lele parti le chef ça compte
bebeaucoup dans une campagne
élélectorale.
M.M. St-Pierre Paul St-PIierre
PlPlamondon va ce magasin ne
cocompter mais ça ne va pas être
fafacile. Un compte Odhiambo un
anancrage mais il est de la régn
dede Montréal. Ceci étant dit
c'c'est pas une obligation la vu
dedes sièges présentés... Monsir
LeLegault n'a pas parti le monde
RaRadan L'Assomption. Monsieur
CoCouillard à Roberval les sont
mumultiples. Au total je pense e
c'c'est la chose à faire.
- - Pour le public en général qi
reregarda Christian, ça ne donne
papas une image de pas j'ai peur
dede perdre je n'irai pas?
- - La politique c'est une espèe
dede guerre civilisée encadrée.
QuQuand tu as le choix de ne va
papas dans un combat où tu as
totoutes les chances de perdre.
J Je crois qu'il se réserve por
lala victoire. Les syndiqués
dedevraient y aller parce que
c'c'est plus noble.
IlIl n'est pas de la noblesse. t
rerespect adresse ne pas se
prprésenter. Lui-même en avait
prprofité de la politique, ce
n'n'est pas juste la morale des
bebeaux sentiments de avec toi.
- - C'est réglé. C'est à cette n
a a parlé cette semaine encore.
LeLes témoignages de la ministre
DaDanielle McCann. Elle a fait n
pepetit peu de pression l'écout.
DADANIELLE McCANN, ancienne
miministre de la Santé, Qc
- - Il y a d'autres facteurs,
mamais le manque de gestionnairs
a a joué un rôle important.
JeJe n'étais pas au courant
ququ'il y avait des gens qui
avavaient manqué de nourriture
etet d'eau. Je l'ai su un moment
dodonné parce qu'il y a dans
dedes centres hospitaliers,
unun centre hospitalier,
unun médecin qui a fait part de
cecette réalité. Tout se passait
tetellement vite. Et encore
unune fois, tout le monde
a a fait tout son possible.
- - Je commence avec vous Miche.
LaLa montre du doigt les
reresponsables des CIUSS qui
auaurait pu le dire.
- - Je trouve ça désolant la fan
dontnt Mme McCann a renvoyé la
baballe au dirigeant. C'était ee
ququi est la ministre est dans s
dédétails son témoignage, il y a
dedes éléments troublants. Elle
avavait eu une réunion avec le G
àà la fin janvier via un avocat
ququi a brandi un procès-verbalt
ququi dit : Madame a jamais été
ququestion de sa. Les CHSLD dans
cecette réunion assez sympa la n
féfévrier?
EtEt Mme McCann n'avait pas de
réréponse. Et c'est pas un
cocourrier qu'une des
prpropriétaires d'un six CHSLD
avavait envoyé et n'a jamais vue
cocourriel. Apparemment la dame
s's'était trompée de boîte. Tout
çaça est désolant de mon sens.
- - José.
- - Oui c'est triste et la
cocouronnait à soulever un des
grgros problèmes, c'est cette
cocontradiction entre la version
dede l'ex-ministre Mccann et dee
sosous-ministre Gendron. Et
HoHoracio Arruda. Les trtrois ot
didit qu'ils étaient au courant
ququ'il y avait une pandémie dès
lala fin janvier et dès la fin
jajanvier elles avaient demandéu
PDPDG des CIUSSS de préparer les
CHCHSLD. C'était le 26 févrierùu
ilil a écrit noir sur blanc quea
dedemande à la sécurité civile t
auau ministère de la santé qui
dodoivent être dorénavant en moe
prpréparatoire pour une pandémi.
DoDorénavant le 26 février. Je e
sosouviens très bien de Horacio
ArArruda qui à la fin de janvier
avavais fait une sortie où il a
dédénoncé l'épidémie de peur qui
cicirculait sur une soi-disant
papandémie mais que tout allait
bibien.
- - Il est venu ce plateau je mn
sosouviens.
- - Il avait utilisé aussi un gs
momot pour se moquer des gens qi
avavaient peur. Ce qu'on est en
trtrain de nous dire ce qu'il
sasavait tout à la fin janvier
mamais que à la population Horao
ArArruda disait le contraire.
PoPour plein de choses là-dedans
onon revient au même. Ça va
prprendre une vraie enquête
pupublique.
- - Christian.
- - Qui aurait su avant mars
coconcernant les faits un
cacataclysme?
C'C'est bien beau mais il faut
êêtre réaliste avant la pandémie
onon avait une idée de ce que
c'c'était mais ne pouvait pas
prprévoir. Je suis d'accord avec
JoJosé qu'il faut une vraie
enenquête. Mais actuellement par
rarapport à la gestion de la
papandémie on n'est pas satisfa.
MaMais au moins cette enquête ns
rarappelle des zones totales de
nonotre société dans les CHSLD.e
totous ceux qui sont morts toust
dodont on a empêché les proches
élélèvera. Ça mérite pas une
cocommission d'enquête. La
cocommission de la santé on a vu
leles pré-rapports qu'il a sorts
etet certains éléments mais je
trtrouve que ce n'est pas très
prprofond. Quant à la couronner,
elelle a fait ça. Je l'ai critié
dadans la fête Echaquan parce qe
lala sortie de son rôle.
ElElle dit faudrait quelque choe
dede plus large de plus structul
etet regarder ce qui s'est pass.
C'C'est plus facile que cela fae
dudu gouvernement. Je pense qu'n
a a une chance de se regarder en
faface. Monsieur Legault n'aime
papas les commissions d'enquête.
MaMais si il y a un dossier qui
mémérite une vraie commission
d'd'enquête, c'est bien ce
dodossier-là. C'est un déshonne,
c'c'est un déshonneur il faut le
rarappeler parce que aujourd'hui
onon est trop jovialiste et trop
dede bonne humeur par rapport à
çaça.
- - José.
- - C'est ce qu'on disait mardi.
J Je pense que plus travaux dea
cocouronner Kamel vont avancer
plplus les contradictions des
didifférents témoignages en
sosortie. Plus les demandes pour
unune vraie commission d'enquête
pupublique va monter.
- - Un petit tour de table avant
dede parler hockey. Ça va
coconfirmer demain, taille du
vavaccin Pfizer approuvé par saé
CaCanada. L'annonce a fait de me
popour les cinq à 11. Monsieur
LeLegault a dit que c'est la
dedernière pièce avant début 20.
CeCe sera une opération importae
JoJosé?
- - Oui. Il s'agira de voir
cocomment ça va fonctionner. Mas
ilil reste d'autres morceaux aui
pupuzzles. C'est la troisième de
dudu vaccin pour les personnes i
onont eu la deuxième dose il y a
auau moins six mois. Il y a de
plplus en plus de pays qui ont
ououvert cette troisième dose à
unune grande partie de la
popopulation. Il en a scellé pls
de 4 40 ans et d'autres des plus
dede 50 ans.
IcIci c'est restreint et les
ététudes scientifiques démontre,
l'l'immunité baisse après six
momois.
IlIl y a trop de Valsecchi faut
rerevisiter. Ce morceau là je
trtrouve qu'il manque.
- - Michel et Christian sur
l'l'opération qui va être annone
dedemain, approuvé demain annone
lala semaine prochaine.
- - C'est une excellente chose n
lele voit actuellement. Ce sont
leles jeunes qui sont les plus,
leles vecteurs du virus. Même
s's'ils ne sont pas très malades
mmême ils peuvent le transmettr.
EnEn soit excellent je pense va
avavoir le même problème de non
vavacciné. On voit déjà des
enenquêtes des parents, et je vs
papas les blâmer, qui sont très
héhésitants a fait vacciner les
enenfants. C'est 30 40 50 % qui
vovont dire : je ne suis pas
cecertain. Il va y avoir un
prproblème grave pour les adult.
- - Je vous demande de parler du
hohockey d'abord.
- - Le hockey je n'ai pas plus
exexpertise.
- - Mais rapidement l'exécution.
- - EA avait une nouvelle idée e
leles enfants étaient très toucs
papar la pandémie.
- - Le premier ministre et ce
n'n'est pas une blague, le premr
miministre dit qu'il formant un
cocomité avec beaucoup de monden
didisant : je veux faire une
lelettre le hockey au Québec. Il
esest allé au Centre Bell.
ReRelations publiques au réel
efeffort de changer les choses
dadans ce monde qui va pas si bn
quque ça?
- - Les problèmes sont réels. Is
onont été exposés par vos
ininterlocuteurs. Il a passé de
ququébécois de la nationale. Le
hohockey n'est plus le monopole
dedes adeptes du sport. Le soccr
a a remplacé le hockey pour
bebeaucoup de gens. Le tamil poe
prproblème il faut pas le cacher
dadans une année électorale, toe
l'l'adhésion que prend un
gogouvernement sont étudiées en
papartie en fonction de l'échéae
élélectorale. Alors Monsieur
LeLegault le cultive la fierté.e
hohockey d'un objet de fierté
alalors on n'a pas besoin de
réréfléchir pour montrer que ça
popourrait être payant pour lui.
- - José il fait vibrer toutes s
cocodes sensibles?
- - Impression qu'il y a une
esespèce de liste qu'il faut
cococher. OK cocher. Fierté
cocochait. Francophone cochait.
NaNationale cochait.
JeJe suis comme Christian je la
cocomprends pas cette langue. Ms
susur le plan politique mais c't
lala raison. C'est clair que tot
esest mesuré à l'aune de la
prprochaine élection comme pour
totout gouvernement sortant.
LaLa question est : est-ce que s
dédécisions qui sont prises ou s
anannonces faites vont dans le
sesens du bien commun? Oui ou n?
CÇa va être aux gens de
l'l'évaluer.
- - Moi ça me met mal à l'aise
bibien François Legault. Mais àn
momoment donné on frise la
dédémagogie. Le premier ministre
dudu Québec il y a des problèmes
trtrès importants. Parler de la
lalangue tout le monde aime ça.e
trtrouve que des dossiers majeus
cocomme l'imposition de la loi 1
auau cégep est beaucoup plus
imimportante que cette
mamanifestation de relations
pupubliques par le ministre.
- - Voilà, c'est dit.
C'C'est presque terminé merci
bebeaucoup à vous trois.
OnOn se laissa là-dessu